[Music]
and i have to press so hard together
with my thumbs to get the penis hole
open enough and then the pea just kind
of dribbles out it's kind of like um
it's like squeezing a lemon but you
don't have all the surface area you know
so you're just trying to
drain your little bee dick
into um we actually don't piss in a
toilet bowl we just pee into like you
know those little serving sample cups
they use at costco to give you like a
little piece of pop-tart that's what we
pee into
uh up here in space
and so it's just gonna take a lot of
energy to just get the
all the piss out
so
energy i had a great weekend
he's back all right i'm all pissed fresh
out of piss yes yep
so what are we talking about i was
explaining how ever since frank ocean
gave us those 25k [__] rings it's made
peeing a lot easier what 25k [__] rings
yeah what do you mean he's like selling
like diamond studded [__] rings oh
that's real yeah wait what
actually yeah this [__] on my dick
flaccid it would look like a beyblade
let it rip
what
what like just like those wings on the
ring with my [__] [__] this is
disgusting but
poking through the top of that [__] is
crazy
wait what my penis would look like a
[__] ancient artifact what do you
mean poking through the top like
imagine this around your dick just limp
isn't this like a like an earring it's
like a prince albert it's like oh i
thought it was like a like a [__] ring
like the [__] that like vibrates on your
dick yeah i don't what is it yeah this
is a [__] ring it's a [__] ring yeah i
thought you
put your whole
[__]
ham through that
yeah i got it
i should be looking regal dude yeah yeah
yeah
so it vibrates or what i don't think it
vibrates it's just for jewelry yeah like
it's just to look sick
yeah that is pretty fire yeah it's a
choker for your penis
penis looking like a big yu-gi-oh card
homie how
do you need
does this come in smaller sizes it's as
big as a basketball hoop
does this fit you guys is this
regulation this is a medium let's see
the other average let's see the other
ones man can we see those other rings
alexa show me the [__] rings see those
are like dangly are those dangly
piercings for you i think those are just
regular earrings i can't wait for frank
to send this uh one of those [__] rings
to drake and then drake just like takes
a picture of the box he's like shout out
frank yeah yeah just all these dudes
it's like frank's story is just all the
people reposting ellie reposting all
that yeah thanks bro
i got the meat ring and they're how much
they two bucks 25 grand you can
customize this [__] yo that [__] says h
bone ring size six what
ring size what oh maybe that's the
actual like ring
did we just make up the fact that it's a
[__] ring nah
nah it's a dick ring
yeah it's [__] rings man wow so yeah man
i know we're doing with uh
our tax savings this year
what yeah tmg studios is going to take a
tax
loss on
on uh the show so we can get a little
break so we can get
the
[__] ring
the penis beyblade i'm telling you dick
dick looking like a baby yeah okay i see
it now yeah nice i put a [__] just a
rip start off
yeah no it'll get hard
[Laughter]
it's a pull to start imagine that [__]
just spinning around your dick yeah
because you know you don't you're not
girthed enough
or just
yeah imagine you getting that [__]
flaccid and you're like hell yeah and
then you get up
and
you're somehow too thick for it well
usually they're made out of like rubber
like they're like bendy
yeah or malleable yeah
not that i know but
not that i know what
because i've worn a [__] ring before
okay i didn't know we were just
you shamed me
for
talking about that in a meeting once
[Music]
i joked about having worn one
it was a half maybe because we were in a
meeting
i was telling no it was like we were
like brainstorming material and i was
like telling a personal experience and
you're like maybe this is too much
and now you're here on the bonus i was
like i've worn a [__] ring before
you made me feel so guilty
for that that my degeneracy would drive
me to that point and then wait here we
are what was the context at work it was
a brainstorm it was a brainstorm it was
me a brainstorm that's good me you kyle
and luke
okay and i made a joke about having worn
a [__] ring before and what did i say
you were like you said that you went ah
hr
yeah but that's different from being on
the podcast
if they wrote on the topic doc time noel
wore a [__] ring
then it would be on the show okay tell
the story what was the time that you
were i'm not gonna do it now no do it
now no i'm not gonna do it now
i don't know i've just
i've worn one
is it bendy
yeah they're rubber yeah
yeah
it's pretty [__]
scary scary yeah why because the one i
wore shakes
oh yeah okay when that [__] is going
yeah you're like
yeah
it's super hard
yeah i don't know it doesn't vibrate it
shakes your dick's like
[Laughter]
all right babe i'm turning it on and it
went left to right yeah yeah
i'm turning it on it's like it just
starts like this
starts vibrating oh yeah we're ready
dude oh wait wait wait hold on
hold on i think i put it oh [__] i
turned up to nine by accident
[Laughter]
it goes down so much
it does so much down how does it do that
how does it do that
oh oh whoa hitting your stomach
ah
turn that thing off i'm trying i'm
trying
i keep turning it up
that's the dangerous part those shits
like
the vibrating it's like
that sensation is crazy because to get
it back to off you have to go to
this to setting number 10. yeah
it's so easy to miss that on accident
yeah then you're [__]
yeah did you see those leg do you see my
picture in the leg things that i got
yes those [__] yeah
was that a vibrator actually yeah no
that's a
yeah everyone thought i was doing
recovery i was just
getting horned up
yeah it's a [__] extraction machine on
the other side of your phone
[Music]
be real yeah
no it's it's like
i was so curious in what they and what
they did because i've seen pictures of
like other people on them and i love
massages and just like being touched you
know for sure yeah yeah i just love like
i don't know like massage chairs i
bought a foot massager one time that's
sitting under my desk there's one dude
listening to this like
uh yeah
continue
um
and i just i don't know so i like i saw
or somebody some company
like hyper ice i think it is they hit me
up and they were like do you want do you
want anything and i was like yeah i want
those [__] leg things
do you want anything yeah so they sent
them to me
and uh
they're crazy yeah i didn't think that
it would be that
intense yeah but these things like
squeeze your legs nice to the point
where afterwards i kind of felt like i
was having a stroke or something oh nice
for like the whole night couldn't really
sleep because my legs like still felt
weird sweet cool yeah really glad we
shared our [__] ring stories
what do you mean
i have the same story yeah you just
more on
this pretty it's pretty whatever yeah
yeah you do it once and you're like man
yeah
then you start wearing it to work and
yeah are you supposed to have sex with
them because i never did yeah yeah
oh i
i thought it was just like an after
workout thing yeah
yeah